hoy en revista de prensa comenzaremos
hablando de Israel a propósito de las
protestas a favor de la democracia y en
contra de las reformas judiciales que
propone el Primer Ministro Benjamín
netanyahu para ello nos acompaña a
nuestra periodista Rosa Pérez más de
Rosa bienvenida y buenos días para usted
Buenos días María Clara bueno empecemos
hablando de una columna de opinión que
está en el New York Times en la que
Peter weiner afirma que no se puede
salvar la democracia en un estado judío
Por qué bien no es un artículo para
dejarlo claro desde el principio que
defienda al menos no explícitamente la
solución de los dos estados pero sí que
reprocha un poco la absurdidad de que se
ponga el grito en el cielo como que
Israel es un estado democrático no al
borde de caer en el autoritarismo cuando
señala Este columnista es un estado que
ha sido calificado por organizaciones
internacionales como amnistía
internacional de tener un sistema
bien entonces lo que dice este artículo
Es que desde que Benjamín neta en Yahoo
recordemos Primer Ministro de Israel al
frente de una coalición de ultraderecha
volvió al poder y presentó esta reforma
judicial no que socava la independencia
del poder judicial dice las advertencias
llegan cada día la democracia israelí
está en peligro dice cientos de
manifestantes salen a las calles los
domingos apoyados por judíos también
estadounidenses para señalar que las
instituciones las intenciones de
netanyahu ponen en riesgo los esfuerzos
por mantener a Israel como un estado
democrático dice si bien estos
movimientos prodemocráticos contra
derivas autoritarias se ven en muchos en
lugares del mundo en Israel hay una
particularidad Y es que las personas más
amenazadas dice por el autorismo al del
autoritarismo de netanyahu casi no
participan en el movimiento en su contra
no dice hay muy pocos palestinos en
estas manifestaciones y también la
reivindicaciones por los derechos
palestinos están brillan por su ausencia
digamos en estas manifestaciones Y por
qué dice no es un movimiento que
promueva la igualdad de derechos sino el
sistema político que ya existía antes de
que netanyahu y su coalición de derechas
tomara el poder es un movimiento para
salvar la democracia liberal para los
judíos y dice los guionistas liberales
critican a netanyahu porque dicen que
amenaza a un estado judío y democrático
lo que es en realidad una contradicción
bueno y quiero que profundicemos en esto
porque el columnista habla de una
contradicción al referirse al Estado
judío y estado democrático bien dice
porque democracia significa gobierno del
pueblo Mientras que el estado judío
recalca que es un gobierno de judíos y
dice en un país donde los judíos
constituyen solo la mitad de la
población del pueblo entre el río Jordán
y el mar Mediterráneo el primer
imperativo el gobierno del pueblo
debería pasar por encima del segundo que
sea solo judío no pero señala como
decíamos que la desigualdad de derechos
entre judíos palestinos y árabes no la
desigualdad ante la ley el trato ante la
autoridad la impunidad no del uso de la
fuerza pública contra la población
Palestina la ocupación ilegal de
territorio los desalojos no los las
demoliciones de viviendas no empiezan
con netanyahuas sino que pues es un
sistema de décadas y que ha sido también
perpetrado por personas que ahora se
califican como moderadas como el
predecesor de netanyahu recordemos Yahir
la Pitt quien en 2019 se expresó de la
siguiente manera que dijo que se había
opuesto toda su vida a la idea de que
Israel fuera un estado para todos sus
ciudadanos y esto Solo para poner alguno
de los ejemplos que señala este texto
que concluye de la siguiente forma
Israel se define como un estado nación
para el pueblo judío lo que significa
que nos pertenece a judíos como a mí que
no vivimos ahí porque el autor no
estadounidense es de origen judío pero
no pertenece a los palestinos que viven
Bajo su control ni siquiera a los pocos
que tienen ciudadanía israelí todo esto
pasaba antes de que natanyahu llegara o
volviera al poder esta es la vibrante
democracia que los liberales sionistas
quieren salvar bueno interesante que el
autor también sea Israel y rosa y
plantee Estas ideas le propongo que nos
vayamos de medio oriente a Asia para
hablar de la editorial del medio chino
global Times que dice que todos los
países son Bienvenidos a unirse a la
iniciativa de seguridad Global en qué
consiste en esta iniciativa fue
presentada ayer por el ministro de
exteriores chino no por pero ya había
sido adelantada en abril de 2000 a 22
por el presidente chino y refleja mucho
esta posición que hemos visto expresada
por wangie estos últimos días no que hoy
se ha reunido en conserga y labrov y con
Vladimir Putin pero que el fin de semana
se encontró con el ministro de
exteriores de Ucrania
dimitroculevano a quien reconoció la
soberanía territorial de Ucrania algo
que culeva le agradeció No pues esta
ambivalencia un poco de China que si
bien pues sea Pin y Vladimir Putin no
sellaron sus su colaboración no su
amistad cuando se encontraron en 2020 y
dos y China viene siempre señala a la
otan como culpable de provocar este
conflicto sin al mismo tiempo siempre se
ha definido como valedor de la seguridad
y de la estabilidad Nacional de la
estabilidad mundial bien en este
Entonces en este documento lo que dicen
es que cuando se cumple un año desde que
estalló el conflicto entre Rusia y
Ucrania y mientras las nubes de una
nueva guerra fría pesan sobre el mundo
China reafirma la responsabilidad
histórica de salvaguardar la paz y la
seguridad mundial y cuáles son los
principios de esta iniciativa bien a son
principios que no dan a nombres y
apellidos No si bien el ministro de
exteriores chinos chino dijo que por
favor dejaran de comparar Ucrania con
Taiwán no vemos en Estos principios
algunos apelaciones muy claras a
situaciones que se dan en la geopolítica
actual no Uno de estos principios es el
compromiso con la visión de seguridad
común Cooperativa y sostenida Pero por
otro lado compromiso con la integridad
territorial de todos los países dice los
asuntos internos no admiten injerencias
extranjeras una gran referencia Pues a
la cuestión de Taiwán y en todo caso
María Clara este documento lo pueden
encontrar ustedes en la web del
Ministerio de exteriores chino en
distintos idiomas y China digamos
defiende que estos protocolos de
seguridad respeten mecanismos como el
multilateralismo que defiende la carta
de Naciones Unidas y también que se
lleven a cabo En plataformas de la que
china es protagonista así como Rusia
como la organización de cooperación de
Shanghai y una iniciativa Rosa que sin
duda los chinos discutirán con Rusia en
este encuentro que están teniendo hoy
Rosa Gracias por revista de prensa Hasta
mañana María Clara